Portland has been content to let
Westbrook shoot those jumpers Lillard
for three
[Applause]
Paul George Miller just drives hard a
little bit of a push out to get a little
tiny bit of separation he does Russell
Westbrook out and a great answer by
Russell Westbrook he just rises up and
hits nothing but bottom on that freak
5:13 floor run for the Blazers George on
the tape
George scores man what a tough shot for
Paul George five flat board CJ McCollum
working on Westbrook McCollum unix out
CJ McCollum has been quiet tonight with
the switch on to Lillard Lillard
kicks it McCullum Lou teardrop is good
off the glass CJ McCollum as we hit the
one minute mark in regulation George
halma colobus is along two for the time
West look gives it to George towards
he'll pull the Midway days and he gets
it and the Thunder regained the lead
here comes Damian Lillard on the takes a
chance to send the Thunder home
[Applause]
dagger oh my goodness
that shot to put them out he went for
Chris
that was forty seven forty eight nine is
fifty points on that was that's amazing
five years ago
hit up three again
yes to win the first round series
[Applause]
for 50 points
goodnight Oklahoma City sees it over
Wow key points on that was not amazing
Oh
five years ago
hit a tree can
yes to win a first round series
[Applause]
for 50 points good night Oklahoma City
sees it over
Wow
[Applause]